welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and as horrifying as HBO's last of
us can be was it originally planned to
be even more extreme in its depiction of
a fungal Apocalypse series creators Neil
druckman and Craig Mason have diverged
from the narrative in the games in some
ways but so far only really in context
the depth of the characterization and
the broader societal causes and impacts
not really in the basic trajectory of
Joel and Ellie that is until episode 4
based on the next episode trailer
footage and various reports from HBO
joanelli will not be headed to
Pittsburgh next but the Pittsburgh game
elements will now take place in Kansas
City in this video I'm going to break
down how The Last of Us Series has made
different choices in the way it conveys
horror a few scary paths they chose not
to take and why in the creative process
of adapting the horror you deal playing
a game versus the horror you feel
passively watching an HBO series on
Sunday nights in the world we're living
in today and a reminder to subscribe to
new Rockstar's new channel the Deep dive
that's going to launch February 17th
with a slate of more investigatory
analyzes of titles that you love
including everything everywhere all at
once so right away the first and not
insignificant change HBO made is the
timeline of the story The Game begins in
2013 the era the game initially released
and players of it would be living in and
then jumps ahead 20 years to a future of
2033 but the series begins in the past
2003 and jumps ahead to our present year
of 2023. this opens up more avenues for
the way the series can play with the
audience's anxieties by setting the
present day events in 2023 it invites
the viewers to imagine an alternate
reality where instead of covid we could
be dealing with parasitic fungi and it
uses things like a series prologue of a
1968 talk show speculating Rising global
temperatures leading to a future a
future that is now our present day in
which we'd be cohabitating in a Petri
dish with endless possible natural
threats but also by setting an outbreak
day in 2003 the producers are able to
freeze the setting in the ruins of a
nostalgic period to us an America that
was in that year so framed by the events
of 9 11 and the war on terror so episode
1 includes shots of George W Bush
includes Sarah asking if the infection
was caused by terrorists and later we
see a guy in the Boston QC wearing a
gourd Lieberman shirt and then various
shots of falling passenger jets in
Austin Texas that is scary now but even
scarier back in 2003 an era when I would
have been the same age as Sarah and I
distinctly remember living next to a
Naval Air Force Base in Jacksonville
Florida freaking out every time I heard
a plane passing over our house and that
leads us to the present day shot of a
debris field of a crashed plane that
Joel and Ellie pass now the game's
opening credits include an audio Montage
of the radio broadcast hinting at the
way the social order falls apart year
after year the number of confirmed
deaths has passed 200. the governor has
called a state of emergency
Panic spread worldwide after a leaked
report from the World Health
Organization showed that the latest
vaccination tests have failed but the
bureaucrats have the power we can
finally take the necessary steps Los
Angeles is now the latest City to be
placed under martial law now sometimes
these sponsor ships are me talking about
hair care but even to get caring about
your hair you gotta hang on to the hair
you got and that's what keeps is for
Keeps offers clinically proven
research-backed treatments to stop hair
loss and improve hair growth two out of
three guys will experience hair loss by
the time they're 35 but with keeps you
can get quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or Pharmacy
all keeps treatment plans are
recommended by a licensed medical
provider and delivered straight to your
door at about half the cost of a
traditional Pharmacy each treatment plan
comes with a full year of unlimited
messaging so you can connect with your
medical provider about anything anytime
keep says a network of Expert Medical
advisors prescribers and Care
Specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
hair growth or just take better care of
the hair that you have keeps as you
covered hair loss stops with keeps to
get 50 off your first order go to
keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com Slash new rockstars we
don't really get a version of this in
the show it's all kind of dropped in
bits and pieces of exposition but when
talking about the opening episode 2 2
that showed us the infection's origin in
Jakarta Indonesia Greg Mason revealed
that HBO's official The Last of Us
podcasts their original plan for this
series originally we had this plan for
this Montage where we saw all these
places in the world and what had
happened to them we just didn't have the
money for it
but we thought it would be really
interesting to see where it all begins
yikes
yikes me just cut into that her and her
child in Lincoln Massachusetts
in the full bombings of Boston and other
cities as their streets were sworn with
infected people seeing the Baltimore Q Z
fall apart as Frank tried to escape It
Whatever nightmares people cities like
New York La Mexico City Johannesburg
Moscow Beijing Tokyo I mean just while
playing the board game pandemic I've
allowed way too many chain reactive
outbreaks in all these cities and I'll
never forgive myself for that so whether
due to budget constraints or just a
tonal choice this series often shows
characters stumbling upon the aftermath
of shootouts and extreme violence I
suspect that's going to change in
episode four Joel and Ellie can't hide
from the bad people forever but it's
just interesting to show how the fungus
dominates with intimate kisses while the
humans use bullets which is another key
difference in the horror of the Show
versus the horror of the game the game
spreads the fungus via Airborne spores
requiring characters to wear breathing
masks the show uses oral transmission
via Mycelia those are the root tendrils
of a fungus this way the transmission of
the fungus in the show is far more
intimate far more visceral and way
grosser for a TV audience this also
gives the benefit of being able to show
an actor's face is and we already have a
Lone Wolf and Cub show with Pedro Pascal
having to cover space and a mask but
really this reflects what Craig Mason
and Neil druckman are thematically
trying to convey with this series the
danger of unconditional love they've
talked about how they want these
episodes to show how love can actually
be a bad thing sometimes and so by
depicting this deadly fungus as once
spread by the symbolic gesture of love
it's psychologically conditions viewers
of the series to view love as a more
complex Force than the love conquers all
cliche that we viewed it as in the past
now Tessa's final moment is also of
course a departure from the games where
she gets infected and dies in a shootout
with Federal soldiers now it's a horde
of infected that finds her and inducts
her into their colony before she blows
herself in the horde to Hell
additionally there was a deeper history
for tests that Mason and druckman wrote
for the character there is something you
know we had talked about and we wrote it
we never shot it
and it was a little bit of a backstory
of Tess and the fact that Tess had a kid
she had a husband and she had a son
and they were infected
and she had to kill them
she killed her husband but she could not
kill the son she couldn't do it she
locked him in the basement where
theoretically he's still a clicker
because we we had it called open we were
just like the camera like pushed on this
door and just hear this pounding coming
from this basement and then we cut out
yeah and then later Tesla told the story
of like how she couldn't kill her son
and just it like Craig is saying it
didn't fit it's but it was fun to think
about it cuts to something that she has
that Joel doesn't want to have again
reportedly this opening shot of a
mystery door later revealed to contained
Tess's clicker son that she could never
bring herself to kill would have
followed Mason and druckman's original
plan for each episode upload to HBO Max
a menu screen showing an open window on
which you would press play like the
loading screen of the game the closing
shot of episode 3 was actually a nod to
this original plan but by removing
Tessa's backstory it lives on only a
subtext and actress and a tour of
carries with her emotionally and thus
becomes implied peripheral horror that
we only feel vicariously from the people
around us I mean let's be real now these
more infectious than some anxiety that
you catch from another person like one
guy in your row on a flight is anxious
yep you're gonna be anxious for the rest
of your day too now episode 3 saw a
major change of the characters of Bill
and Frank who of course in the game saw
a bleak into their relationship Frank
broke up with Bill he left he got
infected and then he hung himself with a
bitter suicide note for Bill but this
series gets built and Frank a happy
ending it allows them to grow old
together and die on their own terms Bill
even says this is not the tragic suicide
at the end of the play which is not a
Romeo and Juliet reference it's actually
a nod to a play called the boys in the
band which addresses The Stereotype of
gay romantic characters often dying from
tragic suicide which you know Frank in
the game does kind of fall into yet by
sidestepping that Bleak version of
events in the game the show does give us
another reason to fear the fear that
comes with something to lose as bill
says I was never afraid before you
showed up that is the fear that now
motivates Joel this is a man who
previously had nothing to lose because
he never really fully committed to test
but now he does have something to lose
with Ellie so now in episode 4 this
series makes its first Geographic
Divergence it relocates the events from
Pittsburgh to Kansas City now game
players know that there are some dark
events that occur in the Pittsburgh
section and while I expect some similar
Horrors in Kansas City the biggest
change appears to be that the group of
hunters in this chapter of the game are
now led by a face a new character for
the show Melanie lynskey's Kathleen so
this is going to transform these Hunters
they're going to be less of a group of
bastard NPCs that get a mow through but
instead embodied by a complex human
being with her own empathetic agenda
that we have to consider but I want to
know from you as people have played the
game or people are just watching the
show what's the scariest part of The
Last of Us for you now you may have
noticed I've been wearing Joel's iconic
flint and Tinder wax canvas trucker
jacket from huckberry you can actually
buy your own one of these by clicking
the link in the description below and
this will support new Rockstar's Last of
Us coverage otherwise underneath the
jacket I'm wearing a shirt inspired by
Ant-Man and the once Guana Mania which
you can get over at nerd riot.shop and
support this company in general and of
course another reminder to subscribe to
the Deep dive and you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]